parler des galères de vacances ok
on aboutit en un petit tableau ce qui
vous est arrivé aux uns et aux autres de
retrouver ce qui a bien pu arriver aux
uns et aux autres alors ya encore une
histoire il ya encore une histoire il ya
encore une histoire laisse trop de
gaston c'est ça c'est ça cp on
s'attendre à des coptes n'est pas là
alors oui oui la gastro j'ai en moi par
exemple
j'ai attrapé la gastro le jour des
attentats du 11 septembre
alors
magali berne a honoré les bains chez
tout le temps
on ce soir donc
j'ai jamais d'anecdotes de quartier à
moi comme vous je sais me tenir ce genre
de choses et non une petite gastro le le
11 septembre c'est qui ça le cinéma ça
c'est bernard vilatte et petits faits
assez berne a annoncé peut-être de quoi
j'ai pas les gars
qui sait qui c'est toi delphine le cern
n'ont pas été pas des noms septembre et
jp c'est moi si je sais c'est terrible
parce que c'était pendant vraiment les
attentats j'étais en vacances en tunisie
sur le club med à l'époque s'appelait
hoyos et leur fait c'était pour les
jeunes et on a vu les images des avions
qui s'écrasent et c'était terrible et
aux os mais c'est pas une collègue au
même moment j'ai senti que j'étais pas
bien et j'ai chopé une gastro donc
c'était vraiment une journée de merde
lire et alors tout fait voilà une gastro
les attentats du pendant les attentats
du 11 septembre c'est pas si c'est une
belle année
comme chaque début c'est comme ça à
chaque visite tout le monde se rappelle
précisément ce qui faisait leur c'est
pour ça que je voulais vous était au
bout du 11 septembre alors moi j'étais à
paris et je terminais un déjeuner avec
mon couturier nino cerruti bon rescue
c'est qui mais comme les autres
il était pas voulu favoriser non leur
travail et gérer des jeunes et que c'est
amer constat oui c'est vrai
moi je travaillais j'étais sur nrj
entier à l'époque et j'étais en pleine
émission radio quand quand le monde
c'est le monde s'est arrêté qu'on a dû
faire tout de suite des breaking news et
et vous vous rappelez moi je revenais de
bordeaux j'étais à l'école de musique et
je rentrais du côté de capbreton un peu
plus au sud et j'ai appris la nouvelle à
la radio on s'en souvient tous accros à
metz a remarqué tout vraiment cet
équipement de six mois j'étais petit
j'étais petit j'étais étudiant encore
apparemment ça vous a marqué lors c'est
bien aller j'ai fait la manche à
l'aéroport de saint petersbourg j'ai
fait la manche à guillaume genton
benvegnu j'ai pas la manche 1 c'est une
manche
mais fait des erreurs
j'étais sûr faire l'annoncé
au mondial est un sujet consacré un
livre romanov les
trois
parties traduit donc tout le monde
voyage s'est super bien passé j'ai
rencontré des descendants de la famille
impériale et tout ça le voyage se
termine et mon vol ne cesse d'être
reculer reculer reculer recul est
reporté donc je vais au restaurant
j'utilise mes derniers roubles qu'il me
reste je suis donc sans argent et bat le
vol est reporté au lendemain à force
d'être repoussé repoussé repoussé sauf
que mon visa était terminée donc je me
retrouve à saint pétersbourg en russie
qui n'est quand même pas le pays le plus
sympathique
ordre de papier bon qu'on m'explique on
m'explique très très vite et très
rapidement que pour être en ordre de
papier il faut payer sauf que en russie
pour payer et de là les cartes bancaires
elles sont composées de cinq chiffres et
moi sur ma carte visa mais je n'avais
qu'à voir le code à quatre numéros donc
je n'ai jamais pu trouver de l'argent
donc j'ai dû faire la manche dans
l'aéroport pourquoi en russie faut cinq
chiffres et bleu dont je sais pas
non sellal et mes cartes visa noces
meinen c'est terry gou poser de
s'incliner ring on a cru que je
transportais une grenade à sa réponse
à ce jour dont celui là non magali
non mais en fait je suis parti dans un
pays
j'avais ramené un cadeau à ses premières
sardines amis et j'avais ramené un
cadeau bon c'était un petit cadeau
vibrant un vibromasseur sauf que ça
s'est déclenché dans le monde paru qui
s'est passé ça que ça vibre et
c'est entendu ils ont cru que c'était
genre une arme ou un truc comme ça tu
vois alors une grenade et j'aurais dit
non non et ils ont ouvert ils ont gardé
voilà voilà voilà
bien arriver à mine fraîche
l'arrivée à miami j'ai atterri dans un
ghetto
des à miami c'est un peu exotique c'est
soit soit vous soit jean ton ses jantes
on sait comment ça il était vous alors à
l'égard non non c'est pas moi c'est
qu'il ghetto bass qui s'est lui dit ça
c'est assez vrai que vous ayez j'ai
beaucoup bah oui je voyage beaucoup mais
à l'époque j'avais jamais mis les pieds
de ma vie à miami je pars avec mes deux
meilleures amies on est en mode sex and
the city carrie bradshaw va faire du
shopping et tout mais les meufs c'est
tellement des races et des pinces un gir
n'ai jamais vu ça elles me disent non on
va pas louer de gps ça coûte trop cher
on va imprimer toutes nos destinations
et tous nos itinéraires on imprime genre
avant de quitter la martinique duvet
encore martinique mais elles sont
tellement conne celles qui décident
d'imprimer le truc elle fait l'aller
elle fait tout court donc on pouvait se
diriger vers des trucs on va chercher
notre voiture on va au restaurant mais
après on peut pas aller à l'hôtel et on
arrive dans un ghetto on voit des gens
mais qui ressemblaient à des monstres je
vous jure il avait les yeux rouges et
c'était vraiment très très
impressionnant deuil et je vous jure et
ils ont tapé sur la voiture et on a
détalé semavip 11 et j'ai roulé tout
droit tout droit tout droit et j'ai
trouvé après chorale guebels un trend à
l'histoire non tôt mais j'avais des
galères bout de deux voyages ou pas
des guerres de voyage où il a du moins
d'arrivées quelques-unes ouais ouais
mais là c'est bien je cherche non non
non mais vers vos dons à installer ça
c'est bien cherché cherché
alors j'ai été à l'origine d'un divorce
dans un avion alors j'entends ça s'est
arrêté pas moins encore bernard
m'arrêter j'aurais dit ludivine
citoyens début de saison
elle s'appelle delphine est le film y
voit lui c'est moi
quelques jeunes et non salonique
en fait c'était sur un vol paris
strasbourg
et je veux briller c'était à c'était
très courageux oui c'était un
bodybuilder mexicain il s'appelait
ricardo il avait une petite amie et j'ai
failli se passe un truc quand on sait on
s'est vus on va prendre les bourrins sex
and the beach on s'est beaucoup
rapproché et si l'histoire qui a duré
quelques mois me l'a dit je suis sûr
c'est
qu'il s'appelait robert c'est ça votre
anecdote non mais ils ont inventé un
truc en 26 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un me mise au ban des
erreurs de réservation j'ai dormi à la
rue schoelcher quand ces deux dans la
rue c'est audel fiancée d'un finisseur
laissez moi moi bah oui c'est moi c'est
moi j'avais réservé à un palace oui
évidemment c'est bah oui franchement
pointé romano à marbella et ottomane la
mairie à 21 des
margueritois j'arrive à crever les sacs
le bordel et manque de pot la résa
erreur ça commençait que le lendemain
donc du coup comme le budget était serré
à la vie pendant qu'en fait vous raconte
comme il avait été invité
il a pas voulu payer la chambre
l'histoire
huissier qui dort j'aurais dû tout ce
qu'il fallait pour dormir à l'hôtel du
coup les hôtels complets au tour
désagréable tu te prennes ton sac bref
j'ai dormi sur la place à un mac à mac
d'ailleurs dans de bons lots tels voilà
c'est pas dramatique mais c'était
l'amour finir ouest m arrêter la partie
tv n'a pas du tout dormi dans
la neige naturelle
confie delphine s'est confondu deux mots
anglais ont nommé ambassadeur
franchement c'est comme ça ça a l'air
passionnant c'est pour ça que j'aimerais
changer l'intitulé non en fait j'ai
invité je vous rpd film vous excite le
principe de la télévision est un
producteur on a par une séquence et on
ne change pas en cours de route j'ai
évité une frappe de missile oh ça c'est
mieux ça ah ça oui ben vous explique pas
mal a interloqué voilà le cas à trois
ans il ya trois ans on est allé avec mon
chéri à honolulu non que robert ait
fauché rongé par mois
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas sympa pour les robert
je l'avais projet donc nous étions à
honolulu on a décidé d'aller à wade est
une superbe lac sur honolulu après et
donc on a décidé d'aller faire un tour
en bateau pour aller voir les dauphins
et on était qu un skippeur évidemment le
skipper reçoit vraiment beaucoup de
coups de téléphone et on voit qu'ils
commencent à devenir tout blanc donc on
va chez lui on dit qu'est-ce qui se
passe il veut pas trop nous dire ensuite
il dit aux autres personnes qu'est-ce
qui se passe et tous les couples qui
sont sur le bateau commence à pleurer
donc nous on est les derniers dit mais
qu'est ce qui se passe elhadi faut qu'on
rentre il ya une alerte miss il faut
vraiment tout ce qu'on rentre tout le
monde commence à appeler ses parents en
pleurant moi je n'avais pas de 4g
forcément ah ouais j'ai demandé le
téléphone portable à une défi là bas
j'ai dit s'il vous plaît j'aimerais
juste appelé ma mère et elle voulait pas
me donner enfin bon bref donc tout le
monde a pleuré on est arrivé donc à bon
port
sur tout l'est surtout les trucs
électroniques là dans la rue là les
panneaux y ait marqué alerte missiles
rentrait tout chez vous vous cachez dans
les caves est tous plus de fous et en
fait est en fait un gars en corée du
nord a appelé soit un mauvais bouton et
en fait donc sa envoyé un message à la
maison blanche aux états unis comme quoi
il y allait avoir vous comprenez soizic
non mais je sais vous savez c'est un peu
long mais non pas du tout belle audience
à décrocher mais tout va bien une frappe
de missiles de la corée du nord c'est
jura et en fait c'est juste un gars qui
s'est trompé un second et la marmotte
armen bond en papillon
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]